oh this is lovely I'm happy about this
crampy crampy Krampus Krampus Krampus
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Krampus is Homer Krampus
or current piece Columbus or Krampus
Krampus Krampus why did me I don't like
that alright so this is a horror game
about Krampus oh ok right I see what
you're going for here I see what you're
doing I don't remember my Mike Sam being
this squeaky when I squeak on it oh what
a lovely setting for a horror game oh
please tell me that's me all right well
this is awkward
Oh Oh huh
I'll just break my neck turning around
there all right I don't know what movie
that is but I'm pretty sure it's not
this game's movie so okay whatever I
don't know what that is probably can't
look at it because probably copyright I
was just watching the movie for a second
there all right what was that thing I
saw outside I guess I can't even go look
I can I'm not allowed out of the house
my parents said I was in timeout been a
bad boy was an awfully big house for me
living by myself and that's an awfully
big dining table for me living by myself
so you want to explain what's going on
when I'm living here by myself eating me
some bricks
oh okay can't do nothing about that I
just got that on the pot for some reason
oh whoa
ball ball ball ball okay can I go out
the front door at least can I see what's
going on out there do I have any
objective at all what am i doing pretty
sure I saw something move on the back
Terrace I better check okay well I'm
trying do I get to go back upstairs or
something oh I'm all tuckered all right
so how do I get to the back Terrace
no no what was that oh it's an app oh
there's something weird going on with
the audio Alec stops every once in a
while what this was was that okay
whatever well there's my bedroom so glad
that I don't have any curtains on there
so glad so many random strangers can
just come up and watch me sleep
it's weird I thought I saw something huh
oh do I have a maze in my back this is
what I'm this is what I'm seeing I'm the
weirdo that has a maze in my own
backyard okay well I'm glad this is
happening oh hi howdy Hootie yes hello
[Music]
all right okay I already knew about that
mom crazy lady you crazy crazy lady
leaving the pressure cooker on like that
I can't believe you it's pretty hot it's
real hot oh god it's so toasty smells
really good too baked we go ah that
should do it
the audio is being real weird oh now
that I'm here I could turn on the
Christmas tree
seems like action for me dear Santa this
year I have been a nice person for
Christmas I would like a video game
console any will do I don't have a
preference and a new bike okay Santa all
right you little scamp you how do I done
whoo I guess I just whispered sweet
nothings into its ear all right that's a
nice tree that's a nice tree I'm real
happy but I won I have any other goals
in life besides those things that I just
did very Oh
so I can't open these can I get out here
I better stay inside it's too cold
outside baby it's cold what didn't what
wait what borrow this laundry room this
is only a washer drying rack and a
washer I guess it's okay all right you
know who am I to judge
everybody lives their own life I'm not
the type to judge let's go back to my
movie and forget that everything ever
happened here all right what's playing
on the floor
what's one laying on the floor what's
what laying on the floor
what do you see laying on the floor whoo
Crouching the deer hates to be ignore
well the deer is about to get a face
full of fists if you know what I'm
talking about
I'm gonna call my parents mom dad mom
dad
[Music]
one of the bedrooms you say what is that
oh oh oh I'm sorry to hear strange
voices telling me horrible things I
don't know what to do about this okay no
idea what to do
hey Krampus I've been a good boy I've
been a good boy I've been a real good
boy I definitely deserve not to have my
my toes ripped out from under my feet
I've been so good let me tell you how
good I been let me tell you how good
I'll be to you that's naughty thing to
say but yeah hey
Krampus whatever you into I just happen
to be into the same things kromm pee I'm
gonna show you a good time if you leave
me alone I know that's counterintuitive
I how can I show you a good time if you
leave me alone but let me tell you I
know how to know how to know how to do
things with my hands okay well I know
probably number one problem numero uno
if it's in one of these bedrooms I can't
see what's in these bedrooms September
29th I love being alone but sometimes it
just does not feel right I hope to find
something interesting to do in this area
oh hey you're boring in the weird audio
keeps cutting in it o.o blue flashlight
it quit oh well ask me what's going hang
on let me I want to see if this is
actually a problem hang on I don't know
if that fixed it i just restarted
everything huh huh if it dude would do
if it don't it don't and there's nothing
I can do about it now oh okay all right
check the fuse box all right what you
want to run that by me again huh it's
still weird but it's I think it's just
part of the game
hello does anybody happen to know where
the fuse is because I for one do not I
guess in the garage maybe or oh no in
the laundry room with the weird lon
that's right
ah where's the fuse by that's not the
few that is the fuse boxes okay much
better mucho better all right okay we're
gonna live we're gonna live uh huh but
why wait bye white um uh hi hello hi
hello Rudolph hey how you doing
the elf hates water great for the elf
think I have a water gun in the
tool-house up oh oh oh I see what you do
ice I see what you do I'm trying to open
this door oh oh that was a bit too close
for comfort
Oh red light green light no I mean sorry
green light red light oh thank you
flashlights almost dead I need to turn
it off to save batteries or find new
batteries how do I turn it off I don't
know how to turn it off
yeah um on equip that's annoying okay
right you you just all the tool sheds
over here I think you just why did you
get to do that I don't like that all
like they don't like that okay open you
find a key table you find a key in the
kitchen of course gosh where did the
deer go oh I guess the deer Oh
I see in the kitchen the kitchen yeah
yeah yeah of course I know who hey bub
hey hey hey Bubba hey don't worry I'm
looking at you
I gots in the corner of my eye you're in
the corner of the apple of my eye your
Apple II in the key in the hey hey back
up back the eff up right now
no you know you don't get to do you
don't get to do that you don't get okay
let's just play a little game I like to
call stay the hell here for me it's a
fun game for the whole family to enjoy
you're gonna go get this oh I don't know
where the key would be they say Hitchin
but I think they're full of lies won't
touch your butt do it touch your
disease-ridden bumpy but I can't get a
good look because this ass whoa okay
give me a second give me a second give
me a goddamn second in the fridge I
don't feel hungry
oh I know I because I got this demonic
little well piece it oh you went that
way okay that's fine it's not here the
bitchin kitchen don't have no key let me
go back outside let me make sure it
actually did say kitchen and also I like
how my first instinct after I get a note
this is like look I'll go get my water
gun oh it doesn't like water
I'll get my water gun then everything
will be perfect sit somewhere in the
kitchen so it is somewhere in here just
don't know where oh there there there
see it got it okay I got that so that's
good and now I can just go open it and
everything will be fine and everything
will be great and everything will be
wonderful why why who where why who
where and why I don't see nothing
I didn't see nothing why gotta be doing
anything to me don't be doing anything
to me don't be turning lights on and off
god we need to fix the foundation in our
house okay
F okay here we go that's awkward okay
open he says of me okay let's open this
okay what are we looking for here we're
looking for a water gun of some type
right there's batteries cool any more
batteries in here probably not okay that
does work okay let's put this away I'm
probably gonna need it in just a second
oh yeah the number one line of defense
Oh water gun Oh water gun oh I got
batteries in my hand all right well
that's useful probably okay it's a deer
yesterday when I was in the backyard I
saw silhouette of something that looked
like an animal was it real
these my notes okay listen friend you
know oh it's not what I was trying to do
but okay you just carry on you have a
good day now
did he leave why oh oh okay all right
this is problem this is problem this is
a problem
I gotta solve the mystery of whatever
the hell's happening hey god damn house
yeah it's all a nightmare I can't wake
up from
okay shoosh oh this those position
position I should recharge it what does
that mean I'm gonna get you no no no no
I'm not oh oh oh you're quite ugly why
did I need to go to the gazebo Oh at the
back of the house I'll be safer in there
oh yeah as we all know the one source of
safety in this world the
all right oh there was a light [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
you dick you big dick you bit Oppie dick
imma be ready for you this time you're
gonna get the jump on me twice
alright put this away get ready here
come on here come at me come at me come
at me bro come at me bro
where you at bro oh there you are oh you
aim and shoot oh no you didn't get me
you got got instead yeah yeah yeah where
you going here nowhere stupid all right
so Hey oh you're a taker don't goosh
goosh I said is this where the gazebo is
I don't know this is the way to the
gazebo Oh God oh why did and dad why did
they have to build this maze oh here we
go
gazebo doesn't help me bench how many
how many makeout benches do you need in
a maze how much action did they think
their son was gonna get the answer is
not now I'm alone alright cuz II bow I
see another note on that table okay you
are coming with me I don't think I am
stranger danger I am NOT coming with you
I need to talk to my parents and tell
them what's happening Bob dad you won't
believe it a reindeer got it and an elf
is chasing me [ __ ] you [ __ ] alright how
did you solve my parents maze kick call
parents again yeah yeah I'm on it I'm on
it
I haven't recharged my gun but I'm on it
don't you worry about a thing
let me worry about things you worry
about being an [ __ ]
Skoosh okay well I'm mr. shaky
is this refilling it I'm gonna assume
that refilled it oh well that's a
problem
oh god I'm got him they think they got
me they do not
hi nope no no no no no no no no no mom
dad dear dear problem
please go back now we're creases are
telling me thanks mom and see I knew
those who's gonna go over so good my
parents they burns never what kind of
parents wouldn't even chop weird
oh I just got survived I can camp out in
this corner I'm a camping bastard do
it's not Bambi no no I'll do it
oh you make me do it you know I'll do it
to you give me a give me a reason give
me a reason give me an excuse I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it I'm a dog I'm a
dog
don't look at me like that okay whatever
I'm gonna get out of here what
well who did that who's that I got water
Bissell
I got a water Bissell
oh oh oh that's problem let me go ahead
and combine oh [ __ ]
what them alright okay Crump II I whoa
whoa I got a water missile I got
arbitrary [ __ ] array of x-ray image oh
wait wait wait don't go okay I don't
know
all right so do when Uncle Krampus
decides to come knockin I bet he can't
climb in a window so what I gotta do is
I just gotta stay outside by this window
when [ __ ] goes down which it will go you
[ __ ] come on oh alright grumpy all
right
where are you at where are you at ah
I'll do it you wanna do it
I'm scared you scared come on baby give
me a reason give me a reason give me a
reason to do this oh [ __ ]
can you are fine okay it's all good baby
no one will know no one needs to know no
one cares
flying elf magic it's in the air
beautiful what a beautiful deer oh oh no
no what the fudge
what the Christmas cracker what the
tinsel is happening here rub peanut
butter on my tin sob I'm really really
not sure happenin
oh hey alright listen that's a good
thing you don't see me cuz boy howdy
this would be awkward I'm pretty sure
it's it's camp here think I could just
camp here I'm pretty sure this is gonna
work I'm a genius everybody else is
stupid
I'm a smarty they're dumb I'm genius if
this is a top-level eye 800 I cube
gameplay right here let me know down the
comments below smash that like button
credible thing you've ever seen yes
right you better run away you know how
to smash that bell ringing that bell
jingle bell that Bell because it's time
to bring it on wash how give me the
stupid baby I was a dumb idea maybe
those dumb unlike this idea of hiding
bots one pillar which is smooth to the
enth degree okay it's twelve twelve
fifty five deer and elf they're just
really floating by that window they
smell me they definitely smell me so
they're just one more I heard you got
probably a checkpoint you know probably
a checkpoint it's one more hour that's
all I got to do just one more hour it's
easy
surviving is he
you're real jumpy who you're jumping
from P don't you think about it there's
my IDs one just grabbed me there oh my
god oh don't get me just because I'm
screaming from behind this pillar
doesn't mean that you get to get me
alright man I'd be back or situation I'd
be I'd be in a hay bale totally safe no
no noise there I should be screaming at
the top of my lungs that comes by I have
the worst instincts oh the answer iam
ever try to stop being such a [ __ ] baby
even though this is like pro level
strategies here almost I'm gonna make
laps around the hop just because I don't
want I don't want nobody at home
thinking that I'm not actually a top
tier 100% player of this game which I is
obviously so Oh
clumpy that's my window what did you set
on the ground over there Center
president from he grumpy is that my
present that my Christmas present you
were but you remembered you remembered I
can't believe a crumb P why did you
leave a present for me you shouldn't
have you shouldn't have grumpy who's a
lumpy grumpy grumpy lumpy I want that
present oh it's gone you took it away
you bastard - let's see if he saw he saw
the news flash he saw he saw okay if I
jump in through here Oh Oh bad bad bomb
I should have stayed in my hidey hole I
should just stayed in my hidey hole but
turn this off cuz I don't need it
think about it
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't [ __ ] it's not fair oh really oh
just one more gonna go back to my hidey
hole good works this worked this work
nobody knows I'm here
everybody knows I'm a cool guy but
nobody knows I'm here and I think that
works to my advantage
cuz as so long as they know I'm cool
they're not gonna come bother me it's
long as I stay buying this pillar I'm
gonna keep being happy does that make
sense yeah who did you why oh he's gone
I don't know what that noise was but oh
I didn't like that one 15 hey you know
what time it is 1:15 time to go Oh dick
poopy I thought be grumpy grumpy Tsar
thumb peeing Grumpy's of real thumb whoa
krump is a real thumb fee I'm never
gonna be I've never there's no it's
physically impossible how could anybody
beat this nobody could nobody could beat
this it's impossible a more hour okay no
I might have let my guard like half a
second but listen be lumpy chrome tastic
mr. krump can the audio please just stop
freaking out seconds I just got to keep
I don't know how to get rid of copy and
I'll try spraying him with every fluid I
have in me but somehow it's still not
gonna work
oh geez right there he doesn't see me
though okay so he might be coming out
here I just need to be mindful and he
might be coming right around this corner
but I think I can wrap around this
pillar no problemo oh here he comes
okay watch this Pro pro level moves pro
pro Brooklyn bro which way you going bro
which way you program okay bro he came
right to where I was grumpy new man I
didn't know the developers program Reap
honest true artificial in this game but
man boy howdy they sure they sure did
time is it a [ __ ] its [ __ ] o'clock oh
[ __ ] okay that's an issue
okay 1:30 30 more minutes that's all I
gotta do grumpy grumpy you freakin [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] nice in the kitchen
risk no no no no no not you not you not
like this not like this not like this
please oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
just here shut up don't [ __ ] god
so we're gonna play that game are we
we're gonna play the game with you're a
giant douche to me and I gotta just sit
there and take it
I just gotta take it and take it you're
douchiness I just gotta take it take it
and take it I gotta eat it up eat eat
eat eat it up
I'm not gonna do I'm done boobie the
poopie is done being eat me I'm not
eating anymore poopie from you guys not
this time not ever the boobie eating is
now done forever and tomorrow and today
no poopie you ask me poopie I say no I
say no to that you offer me a ball
poopie in my cereal I say no not anymore
yesterday sure I'd be slurping down that
bowl of poopie in no time but now no no
I'm a big boy now I'm a big boy with big
boy dreams and i'ma show you how much
I'd not eat the boobie you hear me you
hear me you thumpy grumpy [ __ ] I'm not
eating your poopie I've had enough so
why don't you just take your poopie and
you shove it back up where you've got it
from no not like this not like not at
1:20 a.m. the only time in my life when
I'm poopy free I lend you poopy man I
will with my gun filled with mystery flu
the only thing that can defeat the poopy
oh okay I guess I'll leave I'll guess
I'll leave then my gun is useless on you
my gun sure is useless going away okay
that's quite a thump ooh okay I think
I'm good one thirty thirty minutes
that's all it is 30 minutes 130 okay
I'll admit it's no longer poop free
o'clock down miss okay I think he's
coming out you might be coming out front
front way this leaves me exposed to mr.
Elfman
with the window closed I think that
maybe Elfman might not be flying out oh
he is okay he's coming here we go
evasive maneuvers perfect play action
here perfect play action
the ultimate No let's actually close
that no okay I'm gonna close that cuz I
don't want nobody floating out here it
was loud
maybe he's drawn to loudness maybe me
screaming about poopy at the top of my
lungs didn't do krumping no good 140 20
minutes forty twenty that's easy
what'd you do huh
don't do that okay twenty ten minutes
easy easy
no problemo the ultimate Krampus is home
player in the world top ranked one no
one better no one better
no one ever gonna be better setting down
a present ain't gonna do you no good yet
you come back you come back grumpy you
come to my house and you try to tell me
how to live my life dancer mr. Krum if
that is your real name
mom dad I didn't eat the booby Oh looks
like he learned his lesson after all
looks like it's gonna be a Merry
Christmas
okay all right all right okay you really
got me that time oh no I won't eat it
you can't make me I won't do it I'm a
man of my word and I will not I reveal
oh boy where am I I'm in a prison I'm in
a prison oh boy
yep I sure AM in prison well shouldn't a
skipped out of poopy I've committed the
worst crime known to humanity oh boy
what is this place I have to get out
here escape the cell if only it were so
easy okay
um I don't have time right now to keep
playing so I'm gonna leave this one here
for now I'm sure that there's a probably
a very in-depth kit whoo
I love vaporwave that's it for now so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below I am off back to
Cincinnati for Christmas so videos are
gonna be a little sparse here and but
I'll be live-streaming a bit more I'll
be recording videos with my family with
my
mom and everybody over there so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]